i interviewed xxx tentacion who was
really small at the time he had one song
with a million views but i was getting
all these comments but people were
fascinated by him and they sent me links
to videos of him fighting people on the
street outside of like bars in downtown
miami and i was just fascinated by him
so i did the interview with him i had no
idea his career was going to do that
when i look back at the graph of all of
our views throughout the history of our
youtube channel the day he died was the
day that we got the most views like the
fact that when he died that piece of
content just became that much more
valuable because all of a sudden this is
just like a historical document for
people to understand this kid that
there's not going to be anything new to
understand him by you know like even
before he passed it really changed my
life all of a sudden i had everybody in
the music industry hitting me up like
futures managers tapping in with me asap
rocky's managers tapping in with me and
this is for me at the time where i had
no connections to anybody the music
industry but i did one interview that
just got me on everybody's radar
instantly